uh let me ask for your deep financial
analysis and a very important issue uh
I've just talked a couple days ago Elon
Musk he wants to put a literal Dogecoin
on the moon uh what are your thoughts
about Deutsche coin
uh and uh do you think it'll be the
official currency I may be uh Reserve
currency on the moon and on Mars my
reaction is that's cute I remember Elon
when he first got he first got his money
from PayPal I think he said to me uh it
was um he got 180 million dollars 90
million dollars he decided to say why
aren't we going to outer space and he
wanted to take a spaceship that would be
modified using Russian technology to put
a um
a plant and a watering can to on the
moon
or on Mars I think it was
um and and and he said first life on
mars or first line
um as an inspiring uh notion and so then
there's always what's behind it I have a
lot of respect for elon's ability to do
other things behind it uh and so I would
take that as
um symbolic and I'd be asking him what's
behind it what's what's next and I'm
also just on the topic of Dogecoin and
meme coin and there's some aspect of
humor and light-heartedness
that's that's really interesting about
the way we communicate what ideas become
viral how to Captivate people
with ideas there's something about
taking things too seriously that somehow
slows it all down and it's interesting
you're right that's part of human nature
somehow so like humor is part of this
whole thing